1800 bonsoir bonsoir merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors on va
s'intéresser avec vous à l'évolution du
coronary russe on le disait un premier
français décédés il avait locaux vides
19 mai il est mort d'une embolie
pulmonaire massive
cette embolie pulmonaire à ce que c'est
une conséquence directe de ce
coronavirus oui bien entendu c'est une
forme grave de l'infection atteint
coronavirus il faut rappeler que la
majorité des infections accord avec
glace coronavirus sont soit bénigne soit
peu grave
pas plus qu'une grippe normale mais il y
a effectivement surtout chez les
personnes qui sont soient âgées soient
porteuses d'une maladie chronique
il ya des formes très sévères effets
mortels et l'atteinte pulmonaire qu'on
appelle le syndrome de détresse
respiratoire aiguë qui entraîne souvent
une défaillance multiviscérale c'est à
dire que le rein le foie ne cessent de
fonctionner et bien c'est une
conséquence malheureusement de ses
formes graves et qui mène au décès donc
finalement le profil type des patients à
risque au fond ce sont des personnes
plutôt âgées c'est bien cela vous évite
ou malades
oui on retrouve d'ailleurs les mêmes
personnes à risque pour les formes
graves de la grippe des personnes qui
sont censées d'ailleurs être vaccinés à
qui on recommande chaque année le vaccin
contre la grippe et qui malheureusement
ne sont pas tous vaccinés pour le cette
année on est déjà je parle de la grippe
là à 55 décès en france et sur toutes
les formes graves de grippe qui sont
répertoriés 70 % n'avaient pas été
vaccinés rio donc pour revenir à
l'infection coronavirus
on retrouve effectivement les mêmes
facteurs de risque c'est-à-dire les perd
plus on est âgé et moins on se défend
efficacement le système immunitaire suse
et la défense de l'organisme contre
l'infection est moins efficace
et puis il y a les maladies associées
les traitement au long cours
un des traitements notamment les
traitements immunosuppresseurs qui
peuvent favoriser les formes graves
donc on voulait les patients cancéreux
les patients qui sont atteintes de
pathologies complexes chroniques seront
bien entendu beaucoup plus à risque
d'être victime d'une forme grave
quels sont les inconnus aujourd'hui qui
demeure encore et qui demandaient des
réponses rapides
alors bien sûr il ya beaucoup
d'inconnues il ya beaucoup d'inconnues
parce que ce que nous savons sur le
coronavirus on le tire un petit peu de
ce que l'on sait du coronavirus qui
était responsable du sahara ou du strass
et celui qui est responsable également
de du maire c'est à dire la fiction
comme un virus du moyen-orient on n'est
donc pas complètement ignorants mais ce
coronavirus comporte un petit peu
différemment des autres notamment dans
ses formes cliniques les unes des
inconnus c est ce que les patients qui
sont en phase d'incubation c'est à dire
qu'ils sont infectés mais qui n'ont pas
encore commencé les symptômes et on sait
que cette phase d'incubation peut durer
au moins une semaine
est ce que ces patients sont contagieux
ou ne le sont pas il ya des éléments qui
laissent penser que peut être il
pourrait être transmetteur avant d'avoir
développé des symptômes est ce que les
patients qui font des formes très mineur
asymptomatiques c'est à dire des
patients non repérable des patients qui
ne vont pas consultés est ce que ces
patients lorsqu'ils sont infectés et dès
qu'ils ont des formes donc
asymptomatiques est ce qu'ils sont de
possibles transmetteur on le soupçonne
mais on n'en est pas sûr oui mais ce
sont des choses que l'on saura
progressivement au fur et à mesure que
l'épidémie s'étende en se développant
les recherches
au fur et à mesures vont permettre de
tirer un certain nombre de connaissances
que dont on dispose pas encore parce que
c'est c'est encore très récent cette
histoire de coronavirus armand quand
même en mode des chambres en tous les
cas il y a des consignes pour pour s'en
prémunir le ministre de la santé aux
différents conseils de se laver les
mains une fois par heure il ya une
production de 15 millions de masques en
plus une bonne chose c'est nécessaire
aujourd'hui
alors bon ce sont les méthodes efficaces
sont les mêmes ce qu'on appelle les
méthodes barrières bien entendu alors
tout le monde parle du masque alors il
faut être très clair sur le masque la
plupart des masques que l'on voit dans
les reportages sont des masques de type
chirurgical
ils n'ont aucune efficacité démontrée
pour se protéger par contre ils sont
efficaces
lorsqu'on les places sur les voies
respiratoires des des patients suspects
ou des patients atteints dans des
patients potentiellement contagieux
parce que ces masques chirurgicaux
permettent d'arrêter les flux de virus
et donc d'empêcher qu'il contamine
maintenant si on veut se protéger si on
est au contact d'un malade il faut
porter un masque dont a parlé madame
l'infirmière m'a beaucoup et qui sont
les masques de type ffp2 qui sont des
masques qui enveloppe très très
étroitement le massif facial et cure une
pièce filtrantes
il faut savoir aussi que les masques on
peut pas les garder toute la journée
au bout de deux à trois heures les
masques il faut les changer parce qu'ils
sont d'abord le sol le filtre est bouché
et puis à l'humidité de la respiration
il faut donc une exercice ils sont plus
efficaces
quant au lavage des mains avec
l'utilisation des solutions
hydro-alcooliques bien entendu il faut
lui recommander il faut pas non plus
passer son temps à se laver les mains
parce que c'est venir c'est mais chaque
fois qu'on a eu un contact avec des
personnes que l'on ne connaît pas et si
on a pris le métro un vous les
transports en commun en a tenu la barre
de sécurité
on a un faut se laver se laver merci
beaucoup pour tout ces conseils
professeur yves buisson je rappelle que
vous êtes membre de l'académie nationale
de médecine